for nearly a century
kodak completely owned the nostalgia
market
oh yeah got so much style with that
silly old smile
[Music]
any memorable moment from a child's
first steps
to a wedding was branded a kodak moment
but recently a codec moment has become
let's say
less nostalgic at some point i think
became a crypto company
and now apparently it's a pharmaceutical
company in 2020
the american film giant has made
headlines for his foray
and two of all things pharmaceuticals
specifically to treat covet 19
with the help of a 765 million dollar
u.s government loan
and if you think that's kind of odd
you're not alone
just so many weird themes of america
today i think are wrapped into this
story which is why it's so fascinating
765 million dollar loan for kodak
to begin producing pharmaceuticals turn
another it's a
trump story they're doing something
that's a different field and it's a
field that
they've really hired some of the best
people in the world governor cuomo is
involved
it will create 300 new jobs and the
story of how kodak is trying to become a
pharmaceutical company is just as
strange as the announcement itself
this is how kodak went from selling
nostalgia
to making drugs
[Music]
kodak is a iconic american company
it once symbolized everything that was
great
about america for the better part of a
century kodak could be considered the
closest thing to a monopoly without ever
becoming one
and that was no accident founded in 1888
by george eastman
kodak was born with one mission to
revolutionize the world of picture
taking
he wanted the camera to be as ubiquitous
and as easy to use as the pencil
and he adopted a business strategy that
says
to the customer you push the button and
we do the rest
the rest would turn out to be an
extremely aggressive business strategy
look at what happened in the first 40 or
50 years
of the 20th century scale was the way to
win in this there were a lot of little
camera companies and a lot of photo
companies and photo finishing companies
that sprang up
we got into the camera business by
buying a whole bunch of camera companies
that
not always wanted to get bought
typically that doesn't happen
by just soft management that happens
pretty tough management
by acquiring these companies kodak was
able to not only dominate the camera
market
but the film market as well one of the
reasons it became so powerful is that
eastman understood
either sell the cameras cheaply or give
them away because we're going to make
our money
on film and photo processing and it
worked on so many levels everything was
vertically integrated
you bought your kodak camera where you
put kodak film inside
and if you brought your film in to get
it developed you brought it to a codex
store
throughout much of the 20th century
kodak could do no wrong
every product launched from cameras like
the brownie and the instamatic
to engineering feats in film like
kodachrome and ectochrome
were a hit even creeping into pop
culture
kodak didn't just set the tone for the
film and camera industry
it was the film and camera industry
in the mid 70s 1976 kodak owned
95 percent of the film market and 85
of the camera market in the united
states employment peaked in the 80s at
like 150 000.
this wasn't just a fortune 500 company
this was a fortune 50 company
it was a brand that everybody recognized
and it was
dominant but kodak didn't just do
photography
because of the chemicals used in film
they also developed blood analyzers
x-rays pharmaceutical manufacturing and
copiers just to name a few
what kodak didn't know at the time was
an invention by one of its own engineers
in 1976
would eventually lead to the
organization's demise
kodak engineer steven sassen invented
the prototype
that would eventually become the digital
camera
it was a feasibility demonstration you
saw pictures of it it was obviously not
a commercial product
kodak saw the writing on the wall that
their days while still decades away
were ultimately numbered as a film
business
i began to look at something gordon
moore had come out with
just a couple years before that caught
and it became known as moore's law
moore's law said that the capacity of
transistors on an integrated circuit was
going to double every 18 months
we were able to conclude in 1978
that by about 2008 consumer electronic
imaging ought to overtake traditional
photography
at the time kodak wasn't worried it had
a leg up on the competition and had
plenty of time to prepare
dealing with major shifts in technology
that quickly dated their research
the transition to digital signaled the
beginning of kodak's decline
during the early 80s recognizing this
transformation was coming
kodak set up an internal school where we
sent chemists and chemical engineers
to in-house school to turn them into
electrical engineers
that turned out to be not very
successful if you just look at the
earnings statement of the company
you'd have to say what are we doing this
for because at this point they're still
making money hand over fist
there was kind of an ingrained fear of
cannibalizing that core business of
killing the golden goose
they were a monopoly in film but they
couldn't stop disruptive technologies
you know from
coming along and unseating their
business it's
sort of the classic innovators dilemma
problem
if you have this great cash cow which is
your film camera business and you're
one of the dominant players there you're
reluctant
to totally disrupt it yourself by the
time the 90s rolled around
kodak's push into digital was in full
force
ceo george fisher who headed kodak from
1993 to 1999
pumped 2 billion into research and
development for digital technology
they had this event in san francisco
uh it was march 28 1995.
um they call it the big event um the
chicago tribune remember they had their
headline was the big gamble
and it was it was fisher's big
announcement that you know kodak was
moving
you know full full steam ahead into
digital
and each attempt was a flop whether it
was the massively overpriced dcs-100
the photo cd that could hold up to 25
images which was
quickly outpaced by the growing capacity
of hard drives
and the dc 20 an incredibly cheap camera
that everyone agreed took
awful pictures the disc camera was a
disaster
they called it the adventure of the
incredibly shrinking negative and
it was so small that the images were
horrible
the 90s were also a time when kodak
started spinning off its other
businesses to pay down its debt
selling its entire office imaging
business its digital printer and copier
division
and turning its chemical division into
eastman chemical
in 2003 under new ceo antonio perez who
joined from hewlett-packard
the company once again made the claim
that kodak would become the leader in
digital cameras
kodak is back they're taking this
digital thing to a level undreamed of
they learned early on
that the devices weren't the thing it
was it was what the devices allowed you
to do
it was the it was the follow-on business
all the ancillary stuff is where they
made the money
they didn't have the right kind of
culture to to sell cameras and
digital cameras in a in a frenetic you
know um
low barrier to entry market and to beat
back everybody else
compared with cameras that require film
margins related to the use of digital
cameras are a disaster
film generates a profit of as much as 70
cents on the dollar
digital imaging might make a nickel it's
like that old joke about like we're
losing money on every unit we make but
we'll make it up on volume
in 1987 the company employed 145
000 people at its enormous facility in
rochester
20 years later in 2020 that number has
fallen all the way down
to 4 900 and it keeps on shrinking
i would like to take this time to answer
a few important questions
about kodak in light of our decision to
file for reorganization
with the failure to successfully pivot
to digital complete
on january 19 2012 kodak filed for
bankruptcy
this once great company files for
bankruptcy and now they're trying to
build with whatever you can so you get
jim condenza comes in as the chairman at
that point
is sort of their standard bearer while
this was the end of kodak as mainly a
film business
kodak emerged from bankruptcy in 2013
and started the first
of its many pivots well some investors
are crazy about
cryptocurrencies right now kodak is
launching its own cryptocurrency
kodak coin the cryptocurrency system
will
allow photographers to register work
that they can license and then receive
payment it was coming at a time where it
seemed like everybody was announcing a
coin is a way
to raise a bunch of money because there
was so much mania and so you have kodak
which is a publicly traded company a lot
of the crypto coin ideas didn't have a
public company to latch on to
so you attach this idea to a public
company and all of a sudden
the stock price soars in one day of
trading
shares soared a hundred and twenty
percent going from three dollars and ten
cents
to ten dollars but it wouldn't last
it was widely lampooned i think by the
press i think the bbc called it one of
the worst ideas to come out of ces
or something like that at the time it
was during
legit crypto mania from the peak
of the announcement of kodak coin until
early 2020 kodak stock price fell
from 36.88 to around
dollars and seventy cents until
shares of the company soared yesterday
after news that
the us government awarded the firm 765
million dollars
in loans they just need to become a
cannabis company and a meat-free company
and then they've really got the trifecta
of
all things millennial and gen z most
people heard about the kodak loan on
you know july 28th we have president
trump himself talking about the 765
million
alone we have peter navarro the trade
representative going on tv
talking about it and the governor of new
york andrew cuomo
thanking the president for it that all
of a sudden wakes everybody up in the
world to this
and just like with the announcement of
kodak coin the
share price goes crazy it tops out at
sixty dollars when it had been trading
around three dollars for months and
months for a moment
it was actually a feel-good story a once
great american company
having its second act there's a ton of
media attention on it
everybody's asking why this company can
kodak really do it
why are there all these strange things
about how they handled the announcement
and then suddenly you have everybody
investigating regulators look into
improprieties allegations of insider
trading the
trading volume for kodak shot up
right before the deal kodak after the
announcement comes out
files that just before the announcement
came out they had granted
options to a bunch of their executives
which would seem to
give them access the ability to buy
shares
at a low price dated to before the share
price really surged
codex said it made the mistake of not
placing an embargo on the press release
and without the embargo journalists were
quick to report the news
which impacted trading the source of the
loan was also a big area of interest
it was given out by the u.s
international development finance
corporation
or the dfc this is about investing in a
company
that is going to not only produce 25 of
the generic pharmaceuticals that we need
the ingredients in the united states
but it's going to be financially
sustainable for the long term so they
had a big advanced purchase order
and we were able to give them that money
the 765 million dollars
collateralized on that so i knew we're
going to build a brand
we're going to make americans safer and
we're going to make money for the
american taxpayer
randomly adam bowler is jared kushner
trump's son-in-law's former summer
roommate
so it's it's very trump world so you
have the dfc
uh it's this outward-facing body focused
on international development
but it seemed like you know a friendly
entity in trump world
while a review commissioned by kodak
says ceo jim continenza's stock options
did not violate internal policies
the sec investigation is ongoing
and the damage in the eyes of some has
already been done
what happened at kodak was was probably
the dumbest
decisions made by executives in
corporate history
peter navarro certainly has plenty of
reason to try and distance himself
from this deal you know when he was
announcing it he was trying to take all
the credit in the world
and this was really his baby trying to
shepherd it through and encouraging
the government to give kodak this loan
the underlying question here is
was kodak some sort of pump and dumb
scam or
by shooting the share price up with this
loan announcement
did kodak or anyone around kodak
unfairly
profit off just the share price
skyrocketing alone
in a statement kodak said based on an
exhaustive review of law and facts
our lawyers have concluded that kodak
and its officers
directors and senior management did not
violate the securities regulations or
other relevant laws
engage in a breach of fiduciary duty or
violate
any of kodak's internal policies and
procedures
so while kodak is in trouble both as a
company and
as a company defining its identity it
doesn't necessarily mean that they made
the wrong decisions
some say that companies just aren't
always meant to be on top
it's not obvious that companies exist
forever
the notion that a company has to exist
and if it doesn't exist somebody failed
not accurate the function of management
is not to keep the company in business
it's to create wealth if you don't have
a balance where the revenue exceeds the
cost
you eventually go out of business
[Music]
this isn't just an iconic company this
isn't just a corporate tragedy
it's a piece of america that's being
lost you know forever